now I was reading and I think you even
confirmed that this is the biggest film
that's ever been made in Panama or a
Panamanian production yeah I mean Panama
doesn't have a big film tradition you
know I'm we're from Venezuela venison
has been making movies for a hundred
years like Colombia Argentina Mexico
when we did hands of stone there had
been two movies made in the history of
Panama very small local movies but you
know we brought a dream team of people
from Mexico Argentina Venezuela Colombia
mostly for Latin America people that I
have worked with in the past and you
know use some of the local crews that
existed for publicity and stuff and and
created a phenomenal crew and right now
it's the biggest release for a Latin
movie in history in America in America a
lot of it is in Spanish language and
it's subtitle did anybody ever say oh
that's too much you know you got a you
know have more English in the movie or
you know to make it because some people
don't like to read subtitles I hate to
say that but it's true you know well I
mean the studio had said that III think
it's no secret for our audience that
getting a movie made about a laughing
hero within the system is impossible and
I said sir oh so you know we need knock
on every single door and nobody wanted
to get the movie made the Nero called me
that day when you know we basically
dropped the towel in the United States
and he said you should go to Panama
this movie is important for the world
but it is for sure the most important
movie in the history of Panama and
sometimes money has to have a reason to
invest in a movie and you're more likely
to find that reason in the place where
Duran is a national hero so my wife and
I moved to Panama and we spend a year
there raising the money and we raised
twenty four million dollars in Panama
alone
oh my god that's extraordinary
he went cheese didn't even before Edgar
yes okay yeah I loved before and and it
was that difficult to get a meeting with
De Niro or well getting the meeting was
difficult but the what follow was was
what was really difficult did you know
that he liked my first movie sequester
express and he liked this grip he agreed
to a meeting you know I flew to New York
and he said that you know if you make a
serious boxing movie with me it's gonna
be compared to Raging Bull and that's a
very bad thing and you know then he said
that he loved everything about the story
that Paulie takes the background and
everything that he said that he couldn't
he array ourselves voice did he know him
at all through work he did actually he
met Duran and Ray our sail when he was
preparing for aging bull they actually
plays softball together Panama versus
u.s. and Panama won and ran reminds him
of that every day
and that's what you know gave me the
access a little bit you know I know you
met Iran and and but he said you know he
met everybody very briefly he said that
he was very interesting to him that he
looked like a Harvard professor or like
a businessman and not like a boxing
trainer and you know but when he told me
he couldn't hear his voice he said if I
don't hear his voice I don't know how to
play him and you know English is my
second language it's a miracle that I
learned to write in my second language
so the notion of finding the voice of a
character who was born in Harlem in 1899
was really scary so but that was I was
in New York I walk out of the of the
meeting and I call my wife and I
remember that's deafening ourselves in
New York
stephanie's Ray's wife and I asked her
to find her phone number to see if I can
meet her she can't find the phone number
but finds an address
I get in a taxi and go to that address
in the Indian irk um it says rayar cell
so I knocked on the intercom nobody
answers the guard comes and says you
should go up she never listens I go up
you know worried that this woman must be
94 years old and this you know big
Latinos gonna show up at his door and
scare her so I'm trying to look like a
nice Jewish boy and she opens the door
and I tell her I just met with Robert De
Niro who is interested in this project
about your husband and Roberto Duran and
but he wants to find her hair sales
voice and she walks me in she says you
look like a guy who can use some help
and it's this beautiful incredibly
intelligent 94 year old lady says find
me that notebook over there and I opened
the notebook and she starts reading what
she calls raisins which is basically
things that only Ray used to say which
you can call his voice and she started
reading line by line many of the lines
that are in the movie right now I
recorded her and I send it through the
Nero and said I think I found Ray's
voice and he was blown away by the whole
thing and I started developing Draft
after Draft working very closely with
him he's at boxing encyclopedia and he
knows how to make his characters better
and you know after six months he said
okay I'm doing it how did you get
involved Jonathan called me up Robert
Isis he just explained he had been
involved in the project for for a longer
time and actually I think it was it was
the night of the Critics Choice Awards
in 2013 when it was working on Sierra's
r30 I think it was that night in the
morning or in the afternoon he called me
up I just had have just got to LA and
then we got together he talked to me
about the project gave me the script I
read it that week and then we decided a
few weeks later to do the movie whether
a lot of professional box
in Panama you trained with and you know
did you your diet I'm sure had to change
along with it yeah yeah yeah I trained I
started to train first with Roberto
durán sons with Robin Roberto yeah so
yeah I'll call exactly so Robin and
Chavo just to differentiate but yes
they're both called Roberto so the first
two sons and and they became my first
teachers my first trainers for a while
and then and then I moved to the less
privileged areas of Panama to another
gym closer to what the reality of
Roberto durán as a kid would have would
have been it was very it was very
important to to get to get that texture
and to understand and to understand that
environment to get as close as possible
to that environment in order to the
character and I trained with boxers who
actually trained by the time I was
training with them they had five world
champions who were training with me
every day in the in the in the gym and a
very very humble very humble but but
beautiful place you know did you use the
same locations Duran had shot or Durant
had lived or you know it was it we did
and sometimes we would choose that
location and then here that that is
where it actually happened you know
there's there was an amazing moment when
Duran came to the production office and
started seeing the reference pictures
that the art met Bartman had and he
started saying oh this is where I was
this is you know this is where Chaplin
got killed and we're looking at each
other like we just chose that completely
randomly you know it was yeah I mean you
know without getting very mystical
mystical about it it definitely felt
like something was going on
you know all the way what's not a twist
I ran heavily involved did he come to
the set a lot did he talk were you able
to talk with him a lot about his life
yeah well dren is a very very smart guy
and very sensitive so he he knew that by
showing up too much or for too long
onset would have been not only
uncomfortable for me but for everybody
on set because his presence is very it's
very strong so he would you know come
for five minutes say hi to
everybody and then leave which was very
you know it was very it was very
sensitive was very smart you know of him
and and yes we talked a lot but but he's
a fighter you know and fighters are are
like are like magicians I mean there's
the there's there's a genie in a bottle
that they're not gonna let out there is
there's something really really precious
that they really protect so there were
many things many things that I asked him
that he never really answered and I
think that by yeah a they no mas I mean
all of them course I straight I mean I
asked straight like okay so did you say
they're worse or not and he would not
deny it he would say no but then he
would go you know he would veer and just
like like a little bit like you saw in
the film he's that guy who has like
thousand ideas and they say it says
thousands things at the same time and by
not telling me by not answering those
questions I think he revealed more about
his personality to me which actually
helped me more to build a character did
that help you more just because you
could be that person where you know kind
of instead of dancing in the ring you
could dance with your verbally yeah
because there's always because there's
always that there's always say there's
always a hidden there's there's like a
hidden side to it there's always a card
that he's not that they are not showing
and if you look at the film something
that really there really strikes me
about the about the script that Jonathan
Road is the fact that is it's all it's
all boxing warfare
I mean it's psychological warfare I mean
the movie really focuses on the
psychological aspects of the sport and
and and you could see that it's all
about strategy strategy and tactics and
that is something that yes you have to
you have to achieve for the ring but
it's pretty much how you deal with life
in general so Roberto has always there's
something that there's something there's
a content that he's never revealing and
even even even up until this day we're
friends I mean we've all become family
because actually this is one of those
movies where we're all you know it
doesn't happen in every movie but in
this movie because of all the
circumstances we're all very close
everybody in the film and in Roberto I
go to his house we have we have lunch I
mean to her you know his wife foolish
cooks amazingly and there are many
things that not even until this day he's
gonna actually remember one one day I
said okay let's get him drunk
see if he opens up and in no way said
and I'm drunk and I'm here but you know
there's something that happened in my
life that nobody will never know not
even my wife will ever know it's a real
ittle bit and not even me
not even you I'm not gonna tell you you
know like very opening I said okay
perfect so that right there
helped you so much you know to
understand his his his state of mind you
know did you follow the fights I mean
did you have the choreography did you
shoot it as it has it really happened
yeah it's it's literally beat baby oh my
god what happened did you have a
choreographer or a fight choreographer
helped you then yeah we have had a
choreographer but you know the real
choreographers were Leonard and Durant
you know they they there's no nothing
that you see here that is in a
recreation of a specific moment of that
fight that happened and we actually have
a video that it's hopefully gonna be
releasing in the next few days that
shows the real fights and the fights in
the movie back and forth right it should
be on the DVD yeah and and you know I I
promise you sometimes you don't know
which one is which you know it's really
amazing not only because the moments we
chose but because how extremely accurate
both Edgar and Oscar we're in
replicating the exact movement then I
mean II to a degree that it could be
frustrating because Sasha wouldn't do
something on the left side of the ring
because that happened on the right side
you know and I'm like good this is the
right angle well I really appreciate you
guys both of you coming out and thank
you for coming out to very much